this is possibly the most terrifying
story I've ever read I mean it let me
give you just in Los Angeles they're
arresting young boys and then forcefully
administering estrogen to undergo some
kind of experimental behavioral
treatment yeah that they claim is to
treat some kind of like delinquency or
criminality but there's a family now
suing saying that a 16 year old was
forcefully given estrogen yep forcefully
they told him he had no choice and not
only that the parents had no idea no one
knew they didn't they didn't find out
until like a year or two later
Nosa it was a month later I think okay
maybe the the lawsuit is now as I've
read into multiple different this it's
not just this it's happened other place
oh yeah it's been going on this is not
new so this is some kind of weird
experimental force to gender transition
transition on yep young boys
yes I'm sort of like perverted eugenics
system it's messed up go ahead get into
it boy 16 was given estrogen for
behavioral disorder while in LA juvenile
hall suit alleges I don't think that's a
fair headline because the suit is
alleging that the treatment given to him
had nothing to do with this disorder
they're saying it was medical battery
the headline should be read should
actually read boy 16 was forcefully
administered estrogen against his will
without his family's knowledge right
that's it
right they say this opening line dude a
sixteen-year-old boy being held at a Los
Angeles County Juvenile Hall developed
enlarged breasts after he was prescribed
estrogen to treat a behavioral disorder
a move that baffled doctors who said the
treatment defied medical logic according
to a lawsuit filed last month and that
says to me that is a lie
you know they're experimenting on these
kids yeah it's an experiment you know I
think it was I think technically you can
argue it was for this behavioral
disorder mm-hmm I think these doctors in
my opinion are thinking hey if
testosterone makes young men aggressive
perhaps giving the message in will make
them no longer commit crimes right
them taking it upon themselves to make
that decision scares me
well that's called human experimentation
yet they're doing exactly what's crazy
is we can see it you read this story the
LA Times has confirmed the medical
records this kid was being given
estrogen yep it's it's it's it's LA
Times says it's a fact and fellow
doctors are going this is not oh he it
says right here down here it says
estrogen is not a treatment for OD d I
cannot be more emphatic about that that
ghost said you won't find a reference
anywhere that supports the use of
estrogen for OD D so they're there
they're lying it's not proven it's not a
thing they're making it up there maybe
it'll work look I'll tell you this just
do it this is called what is it called
Oh DD what does it stand for what is it
called behavioral condition my patients
they don't give you the full it's it's
defiant disorder you know something like
that I don't think I've ever do yeah
oppositional defiant you go yeah think
about what that means
oppositional defiant disorder what
you're a young kid who won't sit down
and shut up
hmm they say that the treatment is
therapy family therapy yeah like they
just need a strong father figure yes
reminds you that South Park joke we
talked about before where the the
teacher is like I'm gonna do a
non-medical treatment for a DD oh yeah
and then he's like notice the child is
unfocused and won't pay attention
watch as I administer the treatment and
then he smacks the kid sit down and shut
up and the kid just stops now you see
the child is focused and doing his
homework let's try the next job that's
basically what it is okay you know so
look at this the lawsuit described the
treatment as experimental the doctor who
prescribed the estrogen Danny Wang could
not be reached for comment
they say that they they say that they've
they've checked the medical records
that's legit man Wang prescribed a daily
regimen of two milligrams of estrogen to
be taken in pill form according to
medical records the boy's parents were
not aware that he had been diagnosed
with OD d or was undergoing treatment
until late july 2019 said the treatments
should not have been carried out without
the parents consent
absolutely oh my gosh what should not be
carried out period yeah and then also
without the parents consent no one of
the side effects of high estrogen and
menace
what infertility yep yeah so they just
ruin his life but was was thirteen doses
enough to make him infertile I don't
know I hope not I mean it made him have
it made him develop you know breast
tissue yep maybe so the lawsuit says
that it doesn't say directly they're
doing this other kids but it basically
says the plaintiffs allege that other
you know that young males are being
prescribed estrogen in this facility and
yeah man could you imagine this I'm
gonna say it I'm gonna go ham on this
one every single person every single
time I mentioned you've got to speak up
and stand up against the craziness the
insanity yeah but I have kids okay
alright well let me let you know give me
a call when your kid's been forcefully
administered estrogen yeah there there
was one post where I'm not entirely sure
I read that the first treatment was an
injection and then after that they gave
him pills but I don't know if that's
actually I don't think it's in the LA
Times story may have been in the lawsuit
yeah I saw that that's what spawned me
down this spiral of learning about this
today is when you tweeted it out yeah
about the injection and I was just like
what did I just read so they were they
were giving the kid a bunch of vaccines
too so they gave him like three
different injections what are they doing
in this place what kind of a juvenile
hall is this place this it it blows me
away that I mean low-income yeah we
talked about California being on like
the forefront of like you know
cutting-edge stuff and it's like okay
I'm gonna I'm gonna go ahead and roll
that back cuz they're definitely going
back in time when's the last time people
were experimenting on he forced
lobotomies forced forties electron
electroshock therapy
yeah yeah well we got rid of that I
guess we didn't human I guess we did
it's still prevalent look at this is
happening well eight but be careful
prevalent it's happening okay it's
happening yeah so I I'm very careful I
record some answer ly or like we have we
have this lawsuit this one facility
these doctors yeah it may be just this
facility oh I would I hope that's the
case for exactly exactly so I don't want
to get ahead of myself and act like it's
everywhere it's happening here that's
enough I think to make sure we're being
vigilant calling this out to prevent it
from happening in the future
absolutely
because what you got to understand is
that if you take a young person who is
not dysphoric and forcefully administer
a reassignment therapy or treatment
you're gonna make them this for it yeah
absolutely this kid became depressed has
to get surgery now so they say the kid
requires it yeah let me let me let me
see if I can uh look at this probation
probation officials and the teens
attorney
Wesley out she declined to say why he
was in custody they say out she said the
boy said not seventeen was released in
April and will require surgery to treat
the physical issues he developed as a
result of the estrogen treatment he
messed up that's crazy man this is the
this is some of the craziest of I've
ever heard
yeah me too and and we could get banned
for even talking about it someone in the
chat just said that explains an Tifa
what forcefully administering it's just
the that was like it was a good con man
so the treatments only stopped because
this kid was being bullied he got acne
all over his body and started growing
breasts yeah and the other kid started
making fun of him and so he started
refusing the reason he didn't refuse in
the first place was because he was
basically told that if he gets any
markups in juvie they'll hold him until
he's 18 23 or 26 he's 16 so they were
like you want to spend the next several
years here resist that sounds forced to
me oh yeah according to the lawsuit the
kid said the nurse told him he had to
get medication and he initially refused
saying I wasn't told I was gonna get any
medication and she said it's for a node
in your chest that needs to be treated
what and then he said I don't want it
she said you can't you can't refuse it
has to be done and the security guard
there said you can't refuse you have to
do it he said he was scared that if you
resisted they dried him up and then he'd
be in juvie for the next several years
so we just let him do it then he started
taking the treatment because he had no
choice and only resisted after thirteen
doses and people started attacking him
making fun of him man when I hear about
people messing with kids man it pisses
me off I want to say a lot more than
then we can right now on this live show
they're going after kids man they can't
stand it and remember when Mario Lopez
said a three-year-old
what exactly do say about a
three-year-old a three-year-old
shouldn't be transitioning no no he said
something like a three all doesn't know
if they're trans or something yeah he
was basically spit in fact he was forced
to apologize for that i'll be-i'll
be-i'll before you know look I can say
this I'm not a doctor but I don't think
Mario Lopez had to apologize for that
that's insane that's that's that's
that's the the you know the level of
crazy things are getting with this kind
of intersectional ISM now you've got in
the federal government time racist that
one of that one of the things released
by the by the Army was that using
housing taxes to pay for education see
that's just I tell you this man as we we
talk a lot about China and we're gonna
we're gonna segue over to that in just a
second it really does feel like the
bonds that make a civilization function
are being torn apart in the United
States right and in many parts of Europe
and being put and labeled white right
like a like specifically time and hard
work or the nuclear family just having
having solid parents working hard you
know being respectful like how does that
make any sense
so you said that pamphlet was from the
90s from 1990 so here's the context
there's a pamphlet we read the other day
where it's like listing all of the
things about whiteness some of it
included working hard to succeed time
adhering to schedules right well some of
the other stuff that's being religious
working before play so he's saving up
for the future looking into the future
preparing for the future was whiteness
and and and listen they talk about
abolishing this stuff so this was this
was going viral it was at was the
African American he was posted in the
National African American History Museum
the the official Smithsonian web site
yeah and someone actually and I posted
this on Facebook I'm like this is crazy
like look what's going on someone
someone wrote one of the one of the same
people they're all the same
you know went on there and said wow Adam
you're really going into some fringe
fringe things and posting fringe stuff
and really acting like it's mainstream
media I'm like this is from the
Smithsonian National History Museum
Museum yeah like how you how are you
gonna convince me that that's fringe
this is what did you read it dude you
know read it and try to convince me that
this isn't crazy no not friends they
blow right past it and go how dare you
you post this fringe stuff and I'm like
this is what they're this is whether
teaching people what are you talking
about welcome to the real resistance how
long how long will they allow us to
exist on their airwaves get this though
someone else posted well they're right
that's it period yeah I'm like did you
just do you think time is white you're
telling me I am being polite yeah one of
them eating white being polite is white
really so all those times that you were
polite he was very I only have good
memories of all these people honestly
whenever I've interacted them with in
life so every time they were nice to me
now you know they were being white hey
look man I'll tell you what there's some
light in a tunnel I guess what's that
when everything falls apart
the people who retain schedules hard
work good point Emily structures yes
they're gonna be alright you're
absolutely right these are not you know
these are not things that are white
culture these are things that successful
cultures and general use notably I don't
know the Japanese the Japanese yeah
literally every single country I'm sorry
all of them humans right human
civilization has lasted this long
because of those way that that list
right which which which were created
agrarian agrarian agriculture what was
that was that was that like Egypt I'm
not sure ancient you know Middle Eastern
they grew crops but and yeah it doesn't
make sense because we were
hunter-gatherers
and then we once we started farming we
were able to start sitting in one spot
yeah and that was in Egypt but one of
the areas the funniest thing is let's
say we go aw we're in white no no no
let's go all the back in time all the
way all the way back in time to a very
very early man whatever whatever sure
and hunter-gatherers yeah okay did the
hunter-gatherers have a concept of
seasons probably yes of course depending
on where they were on the planet yeah
different their roots grew and different
seasons and so depending on where you
are on the planet in the tropical areas
you have the rainy sea
in the dry season mm-hmm if you move for
more temperate climates you have the
four seasons and the the moon moon
schedule exactly able to hunt at night
that's why it was sorry it wasn't or it
was fortnight's because those were
between the the moon schedules right and
that was that was important and that was
you guessed it time management
when you woke up when the Sun came up
yeah that is adhering to a schedule yep
what are you arguing that because we've
we've you know quantified units of time
right that's white culture saying time
is a commodity meal you know your life
by this date based on time that that is
not an argument this this stuff everyone
it's really triggering to me yeah yeah
yeah I mean we went over yes or sure so
you can go actually go check out the
video you know right kind of getting
sidetracked here
well no that was just a bit like we're
seeing all this weird critical
intersection Listeria infecting
everything right and I wonder if it
leads to this point where they're like
experimenting on kids it they actually
are you're absolutely right but which I
mean I for all our people not freaking
out about this how is this not the
biggest story in the country right now
right well that's crazy not only that
it's like cuz Trump well what else is
going on right now
you just got who big big profile person
just got arrested a specific girlfriend
of another person who got arrested
killed in jail it's like what are they
trying to hide
why why are people scrubbing their
Instagram accounts their Twitter
accounts why are why is all this
happening yeah hmm maybe they're trying
to hide stuff because they're messing
with kids and well guess what most
people can't stand it when you mess with
kids I'm talking about myself especially
you mess with kids you're you're messing
with the wrong like you met everybody
agrees everybody and everyone I know
anyway that's why everybody wants to see
justice in these particular cases and
that's another reason why let's I like
Trump he's pushing it he's pushing
against these people thanks for checking
out this clip from the Tim cast IRL
podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon
have this podcast up for free on all
podcast platforms thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all in the next
episode
you